[Musique]
et cette invitée aujourd'hui c'est vous
qui avez une balle des bonjour bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être sur ce plateau
vous êtes journaliste sportif
spécialiste du foot africain on vous
retrouve régulièrement dans le journal
du Mondial mais sur la chaîne anglophone
de France 24 et on va commenter bien sûr
cette dernière ligne droite du Mondial
au Qatar au nord au vainqueur si vous
voulez bien les Bleus ce sont libérés de
la malédiction des tenants du titre oui
c'est vrai parce qu'avant la Coupe du
Monde on voyait que les précédentes en
du titre notamment le Brésil l'Italie
c'était pris une claque dès le premier
tour alors on pensait voir la même chose
avec l'équipe de France certains en tout
cas pas moi parce que il y avait
beaucoup de blessés dans cette équipe
parce que Benzema ne pouvait pas jouer
parce que on sentait peut-être un
essoufflement de Didier Deschamps et
finalement c'est tout le contraire qui
s'est produit et avec des joueurs
nouveaux finalement il y a entre
l'équipe de 2018 et celle de cette année
il y a quand même très peu de joueurs
qui restent en réalité et des entrants
qui ont fait la différence on a vu que
le moisi marqué premier ballon premier
but 40 secondes 40 secondes de jeu on a
vu des défenseurs comme Ibrahima Konaté
par exemple parfaitement remplir le rôle
en défense centrale alors que il a pris
la place de ou pas mécano un peu en
dernière minute qui lui-même avait pris
la place de kimpembe forfait donc
c'est-à-dire à quel point même si on va
loin dans le réservoir français il y a
quand même du beau monde et c'est ça
qu'on voit à l'oeuvre Qatar cette année
si on devait résumé leur parcours
jusqu'ici vous étiez quelle qualificatif
pour ce bleu
pour dire bluffant ou tenace
tenace surtout la ténacité de cette
équipe de France parce que malgré les
épreuves malgré les blessures malgré des
matchs parfois compliqués et on l'a vu
encore hier soir face au Maroc
aujourd'hui beaucoup défendre et ben ils
sont au rendez-vous et l'autre terme que
je utiliserai c'est la sérénité des
cadres comme Antoine Griezmann comme
Hugo Lloris eux ils sont en mission ils
ont fait l'Euro 2016 finale Coupe du
Monde 2018 victoire ils ont connu des
échecs aussi comme à l'euro l'année
dernière mais là maintenant on sent
qu'ils sont tranquilles et ils
transmettent cette tranquillité à la
jeune génération les joueurs comme
Aurélien trumani par exemple à des
joueurs comme Youssouf Fofana qui ont
joué hier des gens qui eux n'ont pas
l'habitude des grands événements même
quand ces derniers peuvent faire des
petites erreurs comme les deux penalty
provoquées face à l'Angleterre en quart
de finale et ben ils arrivent à les
rassurer et on sent une Griezmann dans
ses propos d'imprimage c'était ok c'est
bien et qualifié mais avant je pleurais
il y a 4 ans contre la Belgique de joie
là cette fois-ci non on est concentré
sur la finale qu'il ira il y a pas
beaucoup de joueurs qui ont vécu la
finale en 2018 qui se trouve là je crois
qu'ils sont cinq corrigés moi si je me
trompe mais c'est vrai qu'on sent qu'il
y a cette belle osmose entre les anciens
qui restent quand même relativement
jeune et les tout jeune et ça quoi c'est
la pâte des champs qui qui marche qui
arrive à faire le lion oui parce que
Didier Deschamps il sait se reposer sur
ses cadres et les cadres on les connaît
tous notamment Hugo Lloris dans les
cages le capitaine
Antoine Griezmann qui a été énorme ici
parce que oui même peut-être même du
tournoi pour moi pour l'équipe de France
parce que on le connaît comme attaquant
et normalement il occupe il est sous la
lumière et là il accepte d'avoir ce rôle
de l'ombre où il est parfois numéro 10
parfois même plus bas comme hier où il
était quasiment défonce sur centrale à
certains moments du match et il accepte
de bonne foi et en se disant je suis là
pour l'équipe peu importe finalement qui
marque des buts est censé c'est d'être
là de servir et Griezmann non seulement
il est là derrière mais en plus il
arrive à donner des des caviars comme on
dit notamment sur le quart de finale
pour Olivier Giroud et lui aussi Olivier
Giroud d'ailleurs c'est un peu la
résurrection on le donnait hors de
l'équipe de France il y a un an
embrouille soi-disant avant l'euro il
revient en grâce Benzema blessé il
redevient titulaire et c'est lui qui
marque des buts cruciaux dans les
moments importants même si hier c'était
un peu plus compliqué pour Giroud à
propos de Griezmann je vais passer ce
tweet assez marrant en disant qu'il a
les mêmes faire le service d'ordre du
retour du bus
à Paris alors pour revenir sur le
parcours exceptionnel du coach Didier
Deschamps voilà qu'est-ce qu'on peut
dire de de de de voilà son parcours dans
ce Mondial jusque là
il réalise toujours les bons choix au
bon moment certains disent que c'est la
chatte à Dédé comme le veut l'expression
comme quoi il a toujours de la chance
mais c'est pas qu'une question de chance
dans le football et on a vu que cette
année il a fait différemment des fois
précédentes il a réussi à se renouveler
aussi dans son état d'esprit même dans
la tactique par exemple certains
qualifiés des champs de coach
conservateur plutôt parfois défensif là
il a su s'appuyer comme sur la force
offensive de cette équipe de France avec
Kylian Mbappe bien évidemment avec
Olivier Giroud avec Antoine Griezmann
avec même Ousmane Dembélé avec Thuram
qui est rentré hier Marcus Thuram donc
finalement il a su s'appuie sur les
forces de cette équipe on sait que la
défense c'est pas forcément le point
fort cette année notamment les latéraux
qui ont été encore en difficulté hier
mais il a su gérer ça et la su voir
qu'il fallait marquer des buts et
marquer plus que l'adversaire et à
partir de là même si la France a
toujours encaissé un but sauf hier soir
elle arrive quand même à gagner les
matchs Karim ça fait 5 minutes vous
n'avez toujours pas parlé de kienem
Mbappe
collective aussi de cette équipe de
France parce que Mbappé c'est la star
avant quart de finale on disait Mbappé
face à Kyle Walker le latérale anglais
c'est l'être le duel Mbappé était bien
contenu mais les autres ont été à
l'oeuvre demi-finale bapé Hakimi les
deux amis du Paris-Saint-Germain face à
face on s'était focalisé là-dessus mais
au final d'autres joueurs se sont mis en
évidence que le mois ni notamment donc
on voit que même samba P ou même Simba P
contenu il y a assez de réservoirs il y
a assez d'armes offensif côté équipe de
France pour faire la différence à
n'importe quel moment et quel que soit
les circonstances de match contenu et
puis voilà il signe une des très belles
images de ce match hier soir Kylian
Mbappe qui a voilà consolé son copain du
PSG aussi
voilà une photo ça c'est fini ils ont
échangé les maillots oui forcément les
deux amis moi qui suis le Paris
Saint-Germain tout au long de la saison
on les voit à chaque entraînement ils
sont ensemble chaque échauffement
d'avant match ils sont ensemble en
dehors des terrains ils sont ensemble
donc vraiment c'est de là on a une
relation fusionnelle et ça c'est assez
incroyable et là forcément après le
match une fois que la confrontation est
passée le Maroc a fait un très beau
parcours aussi donc c'est une photo qui
résume bien finalement quelles sont
données à tous ceux qui auraient voulu
mettre beaucoup plus que du foot dans ce
match alors pour parler des Marocains
maladresse ou malchance de quoi ont-ils
été victime c'est marocains
d'une défense usée surtout parce que
leur principal force au Marocain c'était
la défense et là quand on regarde
l'équipe de départ les deux défenseurs
centraux principaux Nafa garde
un coup de bluff en l’alignant
soi-disant ah qu'en fait il était blessé
tout ça pour le retirer juste avant le
coup d'envoi romain Saïs capitaine
blessé depuis deux ou trois matchs au
bout de 20 minutes il sort mazraoui le
latéral pareil il était incertain il ne
joue qu'une mi-temps et à partir du
moment où ces jours là ne peuvent pas
être au rendez-vous on savait que ça
allait très difficile surtout avec la
fatigue qui s'accumule la pression et
puis l'équipe championne du monde en
face ça allait être très difficile trop
difficile le coach la reconnu hier soir
la marche était peut-être trop haute
avec une équipe aussi diminue alors
seule la victoire compte à un si on va
la loi du foot mais mais il y a quand
même ce moment historique pour le foot
africain et arabe et ce plafond de verre
qui a été qui a été brisé avec cet
accession en demi-finale c'est vrai
surtout que c'est la Coupe du Monde au
Qatar donc ce n'est pas anodin et
heureusement que les Marocains sont
allés loin parce que quand on voit
l'ambiance dans les stades au Qatar
c'est vraiment variable en dehors des
équipes sud-américaines comme
l'Argentine le Brésil et des équipes
arabes il y avait pas beaucoup
d'ambiance dans les stades donc le fait
que le Maroc aille loin ça a permis
aussi au Qatar on a même vu les miens du
Qatar avec le drapeau marocain
voilà ambiance de folie plus de 40 000
spectateurs en faveur du Maroc voilà ça
a permis de rajouter ce supplément d'âme
à une coupe du monde qui en manquait
dans les tribunes mais en tout cas
chapeau au balai de reggae qui est en
trois mois a réussi à
révolutionné à capitaliser sur son aura
et en ramenant Hakim Ziege qui était le
joueur manquant dans cette équipe pour
justement aller jusqu'en demi-finale et
c'est comme exceptionnel et vous croyez
qu'avec voilà ce coach qui incarne aussi
une nouvelle génération d'entraîneurs
sur le continent il y a un déclic quoi
il y a quelque chose qui veut qui s'est
passé très décomplexé lui sur voilà sur
la capacité de séjour à gagner sans
s'excuser d'être là en comprenant les
enjeux mais voilà avec une en disant on
y va quoi on n'est pas on n'est pas
impressionné par parce qu'il nous arrive
exactement dans son discours dans les
conférences de presse à chaque fois il
martelait ce message simple on n'est pas
là par hasard et surtout c'est pas parce
qu'on est africain qu'on ne peut pas
aller loin qu'on ne peut pas avoir de
l'ambition dans une compétition même
après avoir battu l'Espagne même après
avoir battu le Portugal c'est bien mais
on peut faire plus et ça c'est un
discours novateur à l'échelle africaine
il y avait quatre quarts de finale
précédemment d'équipes africaines en
Coupe du monde à chaque fois il y avait
ce plafond de verre des quarts de finale
là il a montré qu'une équipe africaine
certes avec un état des joueurs qui sont
un peu typé européen dans leur façon de
jouer mais quand même il a su s'appuyer
sur cette force là pour aller au-delà et
maintenant les équipes nationales
africaines vont savoir que on peut venir
du continent africain et aller en
demi-finale de Coupe du Monde et le
clamer haut et fort devant le monde
entier sans problème
et laisser pour prendre une métaphore
qui n'est pas footballistique est-ce que
ça valide l'idée de la FIFA d'une Coupe
du monde à 48 avec plus de place pour
les équipes africaines alors moi je suis
un fervent opposant à cette Coupe du
monde à 48 et à l'inflation des
compétitions parce que ça fait plus de
place éventuellement ça fera 9 équipes
africaines pour sûr à la Coupe du monde
mais c'est pas parce qu'on rajoute plus
d'équipe qu'il y aura plus de qualité ça
c'est le souci on voit qu'avec les cinq
équipes africaines il y en a qu'une qui
a réussi à deux pardon qui ont réussi à
passer les phases de poules le Maroc et
le Sénégal je ne suis pas sûr qu'avec 9
équipes il y en aurait plus qui passe
les phases de poules dans une coupe du
monde à 48 donc c'est le problème et en
plus plus généralement sur ce format là
ça donnera des poules de 3 ça une
formule plus compliquée à comprendre
pour le grand public ça fait une
inflation du nombre de matchs et c'est
pas parce qu'on a plus de matchs qu'on
aura plus de qualité il y aura beaucoup
de match sans enjeu et ça ça me pose
problème est-ce que ça mettrait pas un
petit coup de pied aux fesses des
fédérations africaines quoi pour attirer
des binationaux qui jouent en Europe
mais pour voilà les motiver à jouer dans
leur dans leur pays à mettre plus
d'argent mettre plus de moyens mettre
plus d'argent à la formation aussi sur
place ça pourrait donner un coup de
boost en la matière mais le problème de
fond dans beaucoup de fédérations
africaines c'est la corruption c'est le
fait que les fonds par exemple de la
FIFA la Fédération internationale sont
utilisées à mauvais escient ça c'est un
gros souci quand on voit le Maroc eux
ils ont mis l'argent principalement dans
les infrastructures et dans les
académies de formation là ça marche mais
dans beaucoup d'autres pays
malheureusement l'argent disparaît donc
ce problème là il ne se résoudra pas
avec neuf équipes africaines à la Coupe
du monde il va falloir que beaucoup de
pays se posent des questions le parcours
du Maroc est exemplaire mais pour un bon
exemple combien de une mauvaise exemples
sur le continent voilà le problème
aujourd'hui bon
on va parler avec qui face à
l'arche duel Messi Mbappé ah voilà on
est à 4 jours de la finale 3 jours
avantages forme et fraîcheur plutôt aux
Argentins là oui mais les Argentins ont
quand même joué jusqu'au tir au but par
exemple face au Pays-Bas en terme de
finale match plus long les Français
finalement n'ont pas eu de période
supplémentaires de jeux donc de virus
chez les Bleus il y a les blessés on
verra bien après moi j'espère qu'Adrien
rabiot sera rétablie parce que lui pour
le coup il a manqué je pense au milieu
de terrain arkopam mecano peut-être
remplacé par Konaté concernant la finale
mais si forcément c'est sa mission aide
champion du monde dernière Coupe du
Monde on le sait il annonce dernière
chance pour lui le duel avec bapé les
deux joueurs du Paris Saint-Germain ça
va être incroyable les Argentins vont
avoir les faveurs du stade parce que ils
sont des milliers des milliers là-bas
sur place au Qatar depuis le début de la
compétition tout le monde aimerait voir
mes six champion du monde
ça penche vraiment clairement en faveur
de l'Argentine
comme Leo Messi on a envie de l'avoir
championne du monde même moi en tant que
fan de football j'aimerais bien mais je
suis français et on reste quand même
derrière cette équipe de France et pour
Mbappé à seulement 23 ans d'être double
champion du monde ce serait quelque
chose d'incroyable et il y a beaucoup de
comparaisons avec Pelé bah c'est vrai
que d'être double champion du monde à
cet âge-là ce sera incroyable et la
France quand même mine de rien troisième
finale de Coupe du monde sur les 5
dernières éditions et 4e finale depuis
98 on est dans une époque où nous sommes
nous des générations gâtées on peut le
dire sachant que le 18 donc dimanche il
sera deux jours de son 24e anniversaire
incroyable au mois de décembre pour lui
bon ben on se retrouve dimanche j'espère
bien allez bah merci beaucoup un peu de
repos et pour les Bleus et pour le
supporter que vous êtes bien sûr et le
professionnel merci beaucoup Karim Baldé
d'être venu ce matin sur le plateau de
Paris direct en français on vous
retrouve dans le journal de la coupe en
anglais bien sûr tous les soirs et à
très bientôt nous on se retrouve juste
après la pause avec avec mon équipe et
moi Damien coquet à tout de suite
[Musique]